Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
İnsanlar ne zaman bir çıkış yolu arar?
Veya buna nasıl bir ihtiyaç duyar?
İnsanlar bence darda kaldığı zamanlar
veya hayatlarında bir şeyin
tıkandığını hissettikleri zamanlar
bir çıkış yolu arar.
Ben bu çıkış yoluna karar verdiğimde,
bunu bilmiyordum.
Nasıl karar verdiğimi,
ne yaptığımı bilmiyordum.
Bunun bir çıkış yolu olduğunu bilmiyordum.
Yıl 1956.
Kayseri'nin Yahyalı kazasında,
kalabalık bir çiftçi ailesi olan
Mustafa Efendi'nin evinde,
evlendirdiği beşinci çocuğunun
ilk kız bebeği olarak dünyaya gelmişim.
Ayı günü belli değil.
Ağaçlarda son kirazların kaldığı zaman,
tahminen temmuz başı.
Dedem ismimi Afife Jale koymuş.
Biraz sanata meraklıymış herhâlde.
Ben Afife Jale, o kalabalık ailede
sağlıklı mutlu bir çocukluk geçirmişim.
Öyle söylüyorlar.
Okula ne zaman gittiğimi
hiç hatırlamıyorum;
çünkü benden büyük abilerim,
ablalarım vardı, amca çocuklarım.
Onlar şiir okurken
ben onlardan önce ezberlermişim,
beni elimden tutup götürmüşler,
böylece okula başlamışım.
Şiir okurmuşum okulda.
Net hatırladığım
ilkokul yıllarım, ilkokul üç.
Okumayı çok seviyordum,
okulumu seviyordum.
Çalışkan bir talebeydim.
Sonra dört, arkasından beş.
Ama çok seviyordum okumayı,
bulduğum her şeyi okuyordum.
O arada Çalıkuşu'nun parçalarını okumuştum
ve bir karar vermiştim:
Ben öğretmen olacaktım.
Öğretmen olmalıydım
ve anadoluda
birçok çocuklar yetiştirmeliydim.
Köy öğretmeni, hayalim buydu.
Ve ilkokul bitti,
ben hep hayal kuruyorum, ben işte
okuyacağım öğretmen olacağım.
Okula kayıt zamanı geldiğinde,
babam beni ortaokula kaydettirdi.
Büyük bir heves, coşku!
Ben uçuyorum, hayallerim var!
Ama ne yazık ki annem buna izin vermedi.
Hayır, dedi.
O zamana kadar dedem vefat etmiş,
biz ayrı eve çıkmıştık.
Benden küçük dört erkek kardeşim olmuştu.
"Hayır," dedi "olmaz."
"Ben bu kadar işin altından kalkamam.
Bu, kız nasıl olsa.
Evde bana yardım etsin,
erkek çocukları okusun," dedi.
İşte benim dünyam kararmıştı.
Hayallerim yıkılmıştı, nasıl okuyamazdım!
Ne olacaktı peki,
her şey yarım mı kalacaktı?
Ağladım, üzüldüm, küstüm;
ama çare yoktu.
Annem kararını vermişti
ve kimse onu ikna edemedi.
Baktım bu iş böyle olmayacak.
Böyle mi kalmalıydım dedim,
bilmeden bir karar verdim.
Tahsil yapamamıştım,
ama okumalıydım okumalı.
Ama ne?
Yok ki etrafta!
O zaman eski gazete, dergi,
ne buldumsa...
Kardeşlerimin ders kitapları,
onların eve getirdikleri
okuma kitapları...
Ben bunları okuyordum,
bir de o zaman radyolarda
çok güzel programlar vardı.
Okul radyosu, radyo tiyatrosu;
bunları kesintisiz izliyordum,
takip ediyordum.
Kendimi yetiştirmeye çalışıyordum,
çünkü benim akranlarım okuyordu
ve ben gidemiyordum.
Böylelikle bulduğum her şeyi okuyaraktan,
radyo dinleyerekten, yıllar geçti.
Artık ben bir genç kızdım.
Bizim oralarda çok yaygın olan
akraba evliliği
veya görücü usulü evlilikler vardı.
Okuduğum kitaplardan,
dinlediğim radyolardan
bir şeyler öğrenmiştim.
Kendime güvenim artmıştı,
güvenim gelmişti.
Etrafımda olup bitenleri
sorgulayabiliyordum,
izleyebiliyordum.
Belki aklımdan,
süzgecimden geçirebiliyordum.
İşte o zaman
bir çıkış yolu daha lazımdı bana.
Ne yapmalıydım?
Ailemin veya çevrenin bana verdiği,
bana dayattığı evliliği değil;
eşimi ben seçmeliydim!
Yine ama nasıl?
Bu sefer babam daha çok arkamda durdu.
Babam, bir amcam
ve ben üçümüz birlik olduk.
Hem çevreye, hem aileye,
bir de anneme karşı bu sefer biz kazandık.
Mahallede hoş bir çocuk vardı,
komşumuzun çocuğu;
okuyordu, iyi bir insandı.
Konuşuyorduk,
galiba da aşık mıydık bilmiyorum ama
(Kahkaha)
o benim kocam olmalıydı,
o benim eşim olmalıydı.
Kararlıydım artık.
Öyle de oldu nitekim.
Biz eşimle birçok zorlukları yenerek
1977 yılında evlendik.
Bir dönüm noktası, bir hayat daha
açılmıştı önümde, bir perde.
Büyük şehire taşınmıştık.
Konya o zaman
çok büyük göründü bana.
Ben artık daha özgürdüm.
Eşim çok iyi bir insandı,
beni kısıtlamıyordu,
kendime zaman ayırabiliyordum.
Kitap okuyabiliyordum,
daha çok radyo dinleyebiliyordum.
Böylece geçti,
kendimi yetiştirmeye çalışıyordum.
Eksikliği fark etmiştim tahsil,
eğitim eksikliğimi.
Ve nitekim üç tane çocuğum oldu.
İki erkek, bir kız.
Ev hanımıyım, uğraşıyorum.
İki oğlan, bir kız çocuğum olduğu zaman
bir daha başkaydı hayat.
Gerçekten çocuklarımı çok seviyordum,
yarım kalan hayalimi
belki burada tamamlayabilirdim.
Çocuklarım önce
iyi birer insan olmalılardı,
iyi birer vatandaş, yurttaş
ve iyi birer eğitim almalıydılar.
Ben bunun için gayret edecektim.
Hem kendimi yetiştirdim yıllarca,
hem çocuklarımı yetiştirdim,
ama burada bana rehber olan
hep kitaplardı.
Kitap okumaktan asla vazgeçmedim.
Çocuklarım da başarılı oldular.
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi, Boğaziçi
ve Ankara Bilkent'i burslu kazanarak
üç çocuğum da iyi birer eğitim yaptılar.
(Alkış)
Teşekkür ederim.
Şimdi iki oğlum İstanbul'da,
artık onlar iyi birer insan benim gözümde.
Özgür, kendi kararlarını verebilen,
mutlu, duyarlı birer bireyler.
Kızım yurt dışında akademisyen,
o da orada devam ediyor hayatına.
Çocuklarımla, onların sevgili eşleriyle
ve yeğenlerimle gurur duyuyorum.
Hepsi benim canlarım.
Bu hayat böyle giderken,
bir sıkıntı daha oldu.
Eşim emekli oldu, yaşı 41.
Asker emeklisi.
Artık birkaç yıl çocuklarımızın eğitimi
için Balıkesir'deydik o zaman,
kaldık bekledik.
Onlar da evden gitti.
Ne yapabilirdik?
Bir karı bir koca bir apartman dairesinde,
çok da genciz.
Ya ben düşündüm,
bir çıkış yolu daha lazımdı bana.
Ben onun çıkış yolu olduğunu bilmiyordum.
Gittim, memleketimi izledim.
Sağa sola baktım,
bizim için en iyi uygun olanı
köyümüze dönüp
eşimin daha önce yaptığı babasının
ve bildiği iş olan küçükbaş hayvancılığı
koydum kafama.
"Olmaz" dediler tabii ilk başta herkes,
"olmaz yapamazsınız kolay iş değil."
Ama ben karar vermiştim,
kararlıydım, bunu da yapacaktım.
Ve biz memleketimize, köyümüze döndük.
Çok küçük bir miktarla
on tane koyun aldık,
üç tane de oğlak, keçi yavrusu aldık.
Evimizin bahçesinde bu işe başladık.
Zorluklar oldu tabii,
hiç bilmediğim bir işti.
Ama zorluklar niye var,
üstesinden gelinmek için.
Ben bunun üstesinden gelecektim.
Beni engellemeye çalışanlar
çok oldu, ama yılmadım.
Önce evimizin bahçesinde bu işi büyüttük,
olmayacaktı çoğaldı hayvan.
Gittik memleketin şehrin dışında
bir kurak, çorak bir arazi aldık
çok maddi değeri olmayan.
Herkes bize güldü.
"Ya burada tilki bağlasan durmaz,
burada insan yaşar mı?" dediler.
Yol yok, su yok, elektrik yok.
"Ama niye olmasın,
insan gelince her şey gelir" dedim.
Ve biz çiftliğimizi oraya kurduk,
şu anda yaşadığımız çiftliğimizi.
Büyük çabalar sarf ederek suyu da,
elektriği de,
eh geçecek kadar yolu da geçirdik.
Şu anda çiftliğimizde 400'ün üstünde
koyun ve keçimiz var küçükbaş.
Tavuklarımız var, ördeklerimiz.
Arım var, arıcılık da yapıyorum.
Kedilerimiz, köpeklerimiz...
Orası çok kuraktı,
meyveler yetiştirdik.
İki yıldır sebze de yapıyoruz
toprak getirip oraya ekledik.
İşte bu hayvanlarımızla,
eşimle, dostlarımızla
ve kitaplarımla
çok mutlu bir hayatımız var.
Bu da benim için 3. bir çıkış yoluydu.
Bu da olmuştu.
Bir de benim bir
yurt dışına gitme hayalim vardı,
okuduğum kitaplardan
çok etkileniyordum.
Mesela bir Notre Dame'ın Kamburu'nda
Notre Dame Kilisesini merak ediyordum.
Venedik şehri
bana çok ilginç geliyordu.
Ve eşimle karar verdik,
30. evlilik yıl dönümümüzde
biz yurt dışına gittik
ve bunu alışkanlık ettik,
beş yılda bir yurt dışına çıkıyoruz.
Venedik'i gördüm,
İsviçre'yi gördüm Alpler'i,
çok hoşuma gitti.
Artı Paris Seine Nehri,
Sefiller orada yazılmıştı ya!
Orayı da merak ediyordum.
Ve Notre Dame Kilisesi,
çocukluğumuzda okuduğumuzda
çok korkmuştuk o ışıklardan.
Orada Esmeralda kafesine
oturup bir kere baktım,
"Ey Notre Dame sen bizi
ne kadar korkutmuştun!" diye.
Böyle bir hayatımız var.
Nasıl anlatayım,
yani insanların umutlarının
hiç tükeneceğine inanmıyorum.
Umutlarımızı tüketmemeliyiz.
Sonra bana bazen soruyorlar,
"Afife Teyze bu enerjiyi
nereden alıyorsun?" diye.
Bu enerjiyi sevgiden alıyorum.
Gerçekten doğayı çok seviyorum,
hayvanlarımı çok seviyorum,
insanları çok seviyorum.
Çiftliğimizde şunu ön planda tutuyoruz;
doğaya saygılı,
yaban hayatına saygılı
ve hayvan refahını,
maddi gelirden önde tutuyoruz.
Böyle olduğu zaman doğaya
daha çok katkım olduğuna inanıyorum.
(Alkış)
Benim bu enerjim neden
bitmek bilmiyor diye sorduklarında,
enerjim sevgiden kaynaklanıyor.
İnsan, ben şunu düşünüyorum.
İnsan sevdiği zaman, bu sevgi
kendisini enerji olarak dönüyor.
Bir de zorluklardan yılmıyorum.
Yani zorluklar beni yıldıramıyor.
Şöyle düşünüyorum,
insan bir şeye karar verdiği zaman
iyi sorguladığı, iyi araştırdığı,
daha iyi araştırdığında,
yani bir de cesur olduğu zaman
hayallerini yakalar diyorum.
Ve hayal kurmak çok güzel bir şey,
belki de benim bunların
hepsi bir hayalle başladı.
Ama ben şunu diyorum etrafıma,
hayallerinizin peşinden koşmayın;
onları tutun.
Yakalayın ve hayata geçirin.
(Alkış)
Hayaller hayata geçtiği zaman
insan çok mutlu oluyor.
Zorlukları başardığı zaman da
çok mutlu oluyorsun.
Benim en mutlu olduğum zaman,
Üç buçuk yıl
elektriksiz kaldım çiftliğimde.
Her yere başvurdum, olmaz dediler.
Ya nasıl olmaz,
ben burada bir üretim yapıyorum.
Yani bana yardımcı olunması lazım.
Bak hayvancılık ölüp gidiyor,
ne dedimse ama sonunda başardım.
Üç buçuk yıl Ankara'ya gittim,
Kayseri'ye gittim,
milletvekillerini buldum.
Hatta biri bana dedi ki,
senin yaptığın iş ne ki, dedi.
Senin kullanacağın elektriği
iki yılda üç yılda,
dağda bir maden ocağı
bir saatte kullanır,dedi.
O zaman koy o taşı da kaynat da ye, dedim.
Ben üretim yapıyoruz.
(Kahkaha)
(Alkış)
Ve bunu, yani o elektriğin gelip de
yandığı gün
ben çok mutlu bir insandım.
Çünkü neden?
Bir zorluğu başarmıştım.
Kararlıydım ve onu getirttim oraya,
benden sonra oraya birçok çiftlik geldi.
Yani onlara da örnek olmuştuk herhâlde,
çünkü insan gelince işletmeler kuruldu
hayvancılık üstüne.
Şu anda orası çok güzel,
dostlarımız geliyorlar.
Bir çiftlik evi artık,
insanlar hasret kaldı öyle bir şeye.
Şimdi öyle sobalı bir evdeyiz,
çiftlik evinde.
Yani şehirde olan her şeyimizi bıraktık,
döndük, yaptık, çok mutluyuz.
Herkes kararlı olmalı
ve hayallerinin peşinden koşmalı,
yakalamalı, gerçekleştirmeli.
Bunun için de galiba sevgi,
enerji,
bir de cesaret lazım.
Hepinizi çok seviyorum.
Hoşça kalın.
(Alkış)